newse are coming in the last few minutes  Reuters is reporting that Austria has  stopped a train coming from Italy as two  travelers are suspected of being  infected with the kovat 19 coronavirus  so the last few minutes Reuters quoting  a local agency is reporting that Austria  has stopped a train round concerns about  coronavirus and that comes as Italy now  has the worst outbreak of copán 19 in  Europe and has imposed quarantine  restrictions in two northern regions  close to the cities of Milan and Venice  there are now more than a hundred cases  in the country most of them are in  northern Italy in Lombardy the number of  cases has nearly doubled in the last 24  hours  three people have died to limit the  spread of the virus  sports events have been canceled and in  several regions schools universities and  cultural attractions have been told to  close  you